das was sie hier sehen ist die video
konferenz des neu gegründeten
expertenrat den karl lauterbach ins
leben gerufen hat gestern hat man sich
zum ersten mal in dieser runde getroffen
und wir wollen ihnen mal ein paar namen
zeigen welchen rat sich karl lauterbach
da ins haus hole den hier zum beispiel
kennen sie alle das ist christian
drosten der bekannteste virologe
chefgeologe der charité aber
interessanterweise hat karl lauterbach
seinen expertenrat erweitert auch um
leute die eine andere meinung haben den
zum beispiel kennen sie auch das ist
hendricks trägt er immer wieder andere
meinungen auch vertreten hat als
christian drosten der virologe von der
uniklinik bonn das hier ist melanie
brinkmann auch immer wieder im fernsehen
aufgetreten
sie ist infektiologie vom
helmholtz-zentrum in braunschweig eine
sehr radikale
corona politikerin will ich mal sagen
die sich immer für diese 0 kowitz
strategie eingesetzt hat also da sollten
die zahlen immer ganz herr untergebracht
werden das hier ist viola prise mahner
sie ist eine physikerin vom
max-planck-institut in göttingen also
sehr viel know-how hier den herren
kennen sie auch das ist thomas mertens
der chef der ständigen impfkommission
und natürlich kann lothar wieler nicht
fehlen das ist der chef des robert
koch-instituts ideen kennen sie auch
karl lauterbach ist natürlich auch dabei
und auch der bundeskanzler hat hier sehr
nachdenklich zu olaf scholz der neue
bundeskanzler es sind ein paar gesichter
dabei die man nicht so erkennt es sind
kinderärzte dabei mitglied mitglieder
des ethikrats also wirklich ein breit
gefächertes gremium hier 24 menschen
insgesamt all das ändert allerdings
nichts daran dass es ein riesiges
problem gibt und das hat karl lauterbach
festgestellt als er inventur gemacht hat
als er nachgeschaut hat was hat jens
spahn ihm da eigentlich hinterlassen an
impfstoff an mengen und an bestellungen
und diese investoren tour ergab
folgendes ergebnis
ganz genau karl lauterbach hat das
gesagt die mengen reichen nicht um die
booster impfkampagne zu fahren in dem
wichtigen monats der booster kampagne
fehlt der impfstoff und die situation
ist im februar und märz einfach nicht
besser eher schwerer rückschlag für die
buskampagne also millionen bundesbürger
werden in den nächsten wochen keine
dritte corona impfung bekommen können
wir wollen darüber jetzt mit dem chef
der kassen ärzte sprechen hallo doktor
andreas gassen ja er gas in deutschland
fehlt impfstoff wie schon zu beginn des
jahres wieso wurde da schon wieder so
falsch geplant
offen gestanden ist mir das auch völlig
unverständlich wie man so planen kann es
ist natürlich dramatisch wir haben eine
impfkampagne die läuft wie nie und jetzt
geht sozusagen der treibstoff aus das
ist natürlich bitter ist das impfstoff
bestellt sagen auf die frühere
regierungsarbeit von ex
gesundheitsminister jens spahn
zurückzuführen das ist für uns kaum zu
beurteilen wer da welche fehler gemacht
haben wir glauben immer noch der initial
fehler war schon dadurch gegeben dass
die eu kommission den impfstoff für
europa bestellt hat jetzt wird der aus
allen ecken zusammengekratzt ich man hat
natürlich kaum noch verständnis dafür
dass das land in dem stoff entwickelt
wurde nicht in der lage ist für seine
bevölkerung ausreichend impfstoff zur
verfügung zu stellen aber wie fatal ist
die mangelnde impfstoff bestellung
gerade jetzt zumal die politik ist auf
einen mangel in den praxen schiebt
das will ich nicht ausschließen
offenkundig wird das nicht so getan ist
ist ja auch offenkundig falsch die
praxen tun was sie können das neben dem
normalen tagesgeschäft das ist mehr als
bemerkenswert damit hatte wohl auch
niemand in der politik gerechnet die
erfüllen also jede erwartung wird
übertroffen und das würde auch so
weitergehen wenn wir den impfstoff
bekommen aber wir erleben ja seit wochen
das beispiellose beamten in den praxen
deutlich kontingentiert wird zum teil
mit 24 oder 30 und einzeldosen das ist
natürlich für die normale haus oder
facharzt praxis so wenig da können sie
überhaupt keine planung machen da
empfehlen sie die eben mal schnell an
zwei tagen wir könnten sicherlich noch
mehr impfen allein es ist offensichtlich
von wem auch immer versäumt worden
hierfür die entsprechenden
bestellungen zu sorgen das ist natürlich
mehr als bedauerlich eine impfpflicht
diskussion im lichte dieser impfstoff
knappheit wirkt darf wirklich schon fast
ab so